this is not a scene from a psychedelic  science fiction movie its Mexico City's  new airport to be built next to the  present one which the capital is  outgrown Norman Foster and Mexico's  Fernando Romero one with a membrane roof  design referencing Mexico's coat of arms  Mexico is in that tradition of acting  boldly for the future and that's why I  and my colleagues were truly excited and  inspired by the challenge of this  building because it is more than a  gateway to the nation the 7 billion euro  project is a classic foster construction  over 50 years the airport will expand to  six runways with an eventual capacity of  a hundred and twenty million passengers  a year that's four times the current  site's volume an earlier expansion  project failed after protests from local  farmers construction on the new airport  will begin next year on land which  already belongs to the government with  the aim of opening service by 2020